vous ne savez peut-être à la maison les
jeunes doivent composer encore cet
automne avec des restrictions sanitaires
complexe des exigences de toutes sortes
en raison de la pandémie de kobe 19
étudiés c'est investir dans son avenir
c'est vrai pour tous les étudiants et
pour l'ensemble de la société au québec
selon une étude du cirano le rendement
pour une personne d'un baccalauréat
dépasse les 15 % par année par rapport à
un diplôme du secondaire
on vous explique sa de catherine avec et
professeur au département des sciences
économiques à l'icam bonsoir bonsoir
quelles sont les conséquences de
l'interruption scolaires pour les
étudiants et l'interruption scolaire
comme ce qu'on a vu au printemps on peut
s'attendre à des conséquences qui sont
non seulement à court terme mais aussi à
long terme
on a des études qui nous démontre que
les interruptions de longue durée pour
avoir des effets sur la réussite
scolaire est immédiate mais aussi sur la
probabilité de graduer au secondaire
dallas l'université puis même jusqu'à
les revenus sur le marché du travail à
plus long terme on documents même des
effets inter générationnelle des
interruptions scolaire de longue durée
dans certaines études
donc c'est pas c'est pas anodin une
interruption scolaire comme celle qu'on
a vécue au printemps et comme c'est une
maison aussi concentrées sur les plus
vulnérables
oui effectivement et comme celle qu'ont
convient jusqu'à un certain point en ce
moment parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'écoles
qui doivent fermer
il ya des cours à la maison et même un
jour sur deux pour les secondaires 4
secondaire 5
les cégeps les universités ça doivent
passer à la maison on imagine qu'il ya
des effets là dessus aussi
oui ah ben en ce qui concerne les écoles
virtuel à temps plein il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'études de qualité dans les
quelques études de qualité que qui
existe est ce qu on dénote c'est qu'il
ya une perte de d'attachement à l'école
puis on dénote des résultats négatifs
sur la réussite scolaire ou même les
résultats scolaires en fait
tandis que quand on parle plutôt d
approche hybride des approches qui sont
à la fois à l'école en classe et des
accroches qui utilise la technologie le
les résultats peuvent être en fait
bénéfique ou ça dépend comment c'est
utilisé en fait une super belle étude
qui a été monté par et l'aurait aux
classes à l'université toronto qui
revoit 126 expérience contrôle et qui
ont trait aux technologies en éducation
puis je pense que ça vaut la peine de
lire ça pour les gens intéressés mais si
tu démontres c'est que l'école virtuelle
à temps plein on sait pas ce que ça
donne donc il ya lieu de s'inquiéter de
garde et soeurs actif très longtemps et
comme la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur madame mécanisée hier et
s'adresser aux premières années les
jeunes qui arrivent au cégep locke
commencer ou qui arrivent à l'université
qui commence et qu'il a tout à coup
doivent tout faire ça en ligne est ce
que le risque d'abandon scolaire est
plus gras et du ladder d'un certain côté
ces jeunes des fois travail donc ça peut
faciliter la conciliation travail études
d'un autre côté si ça durait trop
longtemps ça pourrait être
je pense que ça serait très dommageable
parce que tout l'aspect social n'existe
plus puis je le vois dans mes collègues
d'avoir bien on est collé combat sur v
vous me faites pas la meilleure façon de
travailler
est-ce que l'interruption scolaire
conduit et est ce que ça se vérifie
davantage à une réduction du nombre
d'années de scolarité pour les jeunes
oui oui oui effectivement
donc en fait il ya des études qui ont
été menées en belgique entre autres la
tue ont regardé les impacts des des
grèves enseignants et aussi des études
qui ont été menées en argentine sur des
grandes grèves enseignante qui avait
duré au tout 88 jours donc un peu comme
notre camp des milles et oui
effectivement on voit que la probabilité
gradually de seconde à demi nu le nom
mais pas juste seul comme sous des
tentes au samedi jusqu'au salaires
parlez nous un peu de la répercussion
sur les salaires des futurs travailleurs
que c'était interruption scolaire qu'on
a connu et qu'on connaît un petit peu
partiellement présentement en fait les
répercussions pourraient aller jusqu'à
3% perte salariale pour les jeunes qui
sont touchés selon l'étude
question qui avait été fait donc c'est
pas c'est plusieurs les bénéfices privés
des gens dont tantôt vous parlez de 15%
des rendements de l'éducation sociale
le bénéfice privé l'éducation mes yeux
tout un volet social aussi de bénéfice
social qui est au dessus de 10 portant
qui voit vers les poches de lecteurs il
va aussi contribuer à la réduction de
créer ma une meilleure santé et donc
l'éducation et plusieurs facettes qui se
répercute tout au long de la vie de dédé
personnes donc l'interrompent trop
longtemps avant d'avoir des conséquences
va falloir qu'on agite quand on parle de
bénéfices privés ou de rendement privé
c'est à dire que moi notre salaire parce
qu'on étudie plus longtemps en moyenne
lorsqu'on fait des études donc on
constate qu'ils augmentent qui sera plus
élevé que si on a un diplôme moins
élevés inférieurs
exact par exemple ceux qui disent que
pour les hommes ça c'était à peu près
c'est pourtant un diplôme universitaire
baccalauréat versus un diplôme d'études
secondaires parce que pour les femmes se
situe plus autour de 24% en moyenne il
on parle de données québécoises
donc c'est vraiment des pêcheurs est
estimée pour le québec est-ce que compte
tenu de la durée de ce qui se passe
présentement est ce que vous êtes d'avis
que c'est toute une génération qui est
affecté par ce qui se passe présentement
oui moi je certainement que ce n'est pas
juste une génération c'est la génération
qui va suivre donc
il ya des déserts quimper générationnel
ascari donc la façon dont on va gérer
cette crise là puis les outils qu'on va
mettre en place pour essayer de pallier
aux dommages qui ont été engendrées par
la crise on est très important dans les
années à venir
pas quelque chose qu'on va pouvoir
régler en grand une ou deux années ça va
prendre du temps les enfants ont une
capacité d'apprentissage relativement
fixe donc c'est pas comme si demain
matin on leur donnait 60 heures d'études
ihs pourrait rattraper le temps perdu
merci beaucoup catherine ex c'est
important de parler de cela très
important merci beaucoup
oui merci bonne journée